[Music]
and movies were made for each other
decades before talkies movies had music
they needed music
and music needed them right back these
are the nominees
for best score the five bloods
by terence blanchard
mank by trent resner and atticus ross
minari by emil mussare
news of the world by james newton
newton-howard
sold by trent rezner atticus ross and
john batiste
and the oscar goes to
trent reznor atticus ross and john
bautista
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
hello hello
man you know what's deep is is that um
god gave us 12 notes
it's the same 12 notes duke ellington
had
bach had it's the same 12 nina simone
and all the nominees i just want to
first point out that every gift is
special
every contribution with music that comes
from the divine
into the instruments into the film
into the minds and hearts and souls of
of
every person who hears it the stories
that happen when you
listen to it and watch it and the
stories you share the moments you create
the memories you make
man it's just so incredibly special and
and and i just want to first recognize
the nominees
and say that i'm i'm incredibly i'm
speaking for all of us
we are incredibly humbled and grateful
to the academy
for this recognition and i'm just
thankful to god for those 12 notes man
that's so dope
thank you to my parents suleika for your
support and love
coming here with me flew on the plane
first time in the year
my parents took me around clubs in new
orleans when i was 10 years old
put me in piano lessons but shirley
william
[Music]
just so much so much has happened
this moment is a culmination of a series
of miracles
and i just can't even go into all of it
we only have much time but it's just so
incredibly powerful to be standing here
in the lineage that
we come from in a lineage in this film
the collaborators on this film are the
best that you could have ever asked for
the most generous
rigorously visionary collaborate pete
doctor is a
i love this man pete doctor he's a
genius and a visionary
dana murray kent powers tom mcdougall at
disney thank you for welcoming us
to the family with open arms so much of
a
of a true collaborative process
um my team thank you all for just
dealing with me because my
i get ideas all the time changing
direction y'all holding me down michael
chris adam all the people and uh thank
you all so much for doing
what y'all do and putting it on the line
putting yourself out there it's hard to
put yourself out there
just thank y'all for putting yourself
out there i'm a fan of like
everybody here so much love much light
to you i love you even if i don't know
you
later on